I want to rip their faces off that's
exactly right thank you for using one of
my favorite term are there any parallels
looking for the next company garyvee
ladies and gents that means like where
you brain works if you will have Eldin
directly to your brand of whatever
you're trying to accomplish office
there's plenty of time get your other
make Monday morning my [ __ ] the fact
that things at been really is the best
that makes me so happy
did you get that with me like you signed
up Sam you sign up for a pen living with
me right welcome to the great nation
your weekly wide journey our guest today
is one of my all-time favorite people in
the one Gary Vaynerchuk will talk live
tech social media hustle
entrepreneurship and a bunch of other
stuff we'll also take the great khali
cab with Gary on the weekly wine sir
I'm your host stamp at Ruby's stay with
us to the great nation on the heritage
radio network we bring wine to the
people
all right fresh out of college Gary
Vaynerchuk fresh out of college was a
stretch that's a guaranteed shot grew
his family wine business the Wine
Library New Jersey from about three
million 60 million dollars in just five
years during that time years among the
first teams the Internet to promote the
wine store and also created the wildly
popular Wine Library TV he now runs the
intermedia one of the world's hottest
digital advertising and marketing
agencies serving fortune 500 companies
along the way he became a prolific angel
investor and venture capitalist
investing in companies maybe you heard
some of these like Facebook Twitter
Tumblr Boober and snapchat among others
before eventually co-founding being or
RSD a multi multi-million dollar fund
investing in tomorrow's companies you
can also see Gary on a regular basis or
the daily mean and the askgaryvee show
on the Internet Gary Vaynerchuk is also
a New York Times best selling author for
ten more times over a very sought-after
public speaker the king of the keynote I
like that welcome to the great nation
Gary oh the clapping I like this Ben
Ruby I'm super excited way down listen
to me yes a lot of people know you yeah
I'm going to assume that our heritage
ratio yes listeners don't know okay you
have a very very interesting colorful
sort of journey to where you are today
yes I think they'd love to hear about it
milos 20 minutes I was doing my first
book signing in Columbus Circle I had a
huge crowd and some weird guy with a
huge mustache is like you need to be on
radio and he just would never leave me
alone and that is your host here
everybody mr. Ben Ruby and so that is
that series which was a lot of fun and
let me tell you listening to his early
kind of remarks here I was way better on
the radio than he was and it was your
show co-host I mean listen I brought you
in all the time because I needed that
crutch and now to watch you now be the
star of your own radio show I'm very
excited I'm very humbled to be here I'm
also a proud employer of your entire
family and I'm really excited about this
I mean this is going to be an all-time
classic to watch but my story is very
simple it's actually quite classic it's
very much a lot of people's
grandfather's story which is my family
emigrated from the Soviet Union and I
was a merchant like just a clam you know
lemonade stands baseball cards that led
to me being involved in my dad's liquor
store I hated beer wine wait oh I'm
money dance yeah I I tried to sell my
sister I mean I was out of control I
mean like you know my pride my family
this weekend we were we were celebrating
Thanksgiving and my dad was making the
joke that if you day was around when I
was in in high school
that he would come home one day and who
wouldn't a single thing in the house I
have high energy no question and by the
way it's driven by gratitude and the
understanding of all the opportunities
we had if you're sitting and listening
to this and you don't understand the
opportunities we have you know it's a
losing formula because there's so much
opportunity there's so much opportunity
for the ones that understand themselves
I deployed a lot of self awareness at a
young age which allowed me to be a poor
student but homeless skills that have
become the foundation in my life which
are people skills emotional intelligence
salesmanship business structures went on
to do the intro so we don't need to go
into that case
some kids were not built four years of
high school four years ago parents
didn't recognize that and didn't nurture
knowledge your mom gave you the support
in the space perfectly parented the book
that I will write one day that will
speak to how two ways an entrepreneur
from an entrepreneurs perspective of
being perfectly parented and yeah and I
think it's interesting Sam you know it's
we're starting to see the conversation
amongst parents to having an open mind
of allowing their kids to do different
things and it's very exciting for me to
see because I grew up in 80s and 90s
when going to a good college was the
single blueprint when I was making
$3,000 a weekend selling baseball cards
but getting a Dean in science I was a
loser today I'd be on the cover of ink
are you kidding I'd be on the cover of
Fast Company right now and so it's very
interesting to see the the world change
so this is one show okay so we got a I'm
excited that they're not going to talk
so I can see that we have a set of gams
Anabella you know we start with the
winding it's sort of reminiscent of wine
and web yes we're we talk a little about
my talk
but anything in the past I mean you
wanna I did sit down with that no but I
mean you from a wine standpoint no look
at anything else no no I feel great
about everything all right so most of
your life was consumed with wine alcohol
not that long that's right you know I
mean family business your dad from kids
got involved with running the business
mine library TV maybe D in this matter
yes but but there's some now I'll tell
you how in a fun well first of all I
mean I was literally texting with
Brandon right now writing tomorrow's
wine offer scary story my dad sascha
store by the way if the people listening
yeah yeah i'ma tell you tell you kill
you um listen I think that on a couple
things emerge so just for everybody who
I know a lot of you don't know who I am
from 15 to 34 it's probably the only
thing I cared about except for the tail
end of baseball cards of 15 and and the
beginning of technology at 30 so like it
is the core of my life my obsession
passion of wine and the wine business
and then what I didn't realize and it's
giving you the answer I drank a dal
Forno Amarone last night seven years ago
I would have drank that and everything
that would have been happening in that
moment was who could I sell this to
what's the margin how do I get more of
an allocation and last night I just
dragged him like my god this is really
good
it's crazy xever think about memory for
everybody was listening if you grew up
in the sports business for us oh my god
that athlete oh my god this use your the
an amazing of media career right people
frequent a meant Howard Stern is your
normal day-to-day you know what you
learn and what everybody listening knows
is no matter what you do for a living
when you're deep in it you start moving
easily forgetting what made it magical
you know you went to Hollywood to make
it you kind of make it the first 15
times you saw stars you wash their mind
you text your mom you called your mom
back in a day Netta that's right and so
what happened was I it was a commodity
that I sold
I loved the business I loved the farmers
the artists the winemakers I loved it I
loved it but it became my business it
was always only my business it's no
different in social retail by the way
people ask always ask me what's my
favorite social media platform I've only
known it from the business standpoint I
didn't grow up with one I went on
Twitter and Facebook are we to go
business so I'd never had a natural
relationship with social networks and so
business and personal yeah personal is
for me that's right that's right and so
and so what's half of your two Salmons
I've actually become a wine consumer and
it's been fun
so last Anna
so as a consumer and having the past are
there any trends or anything going on in
wine that you notice now yeah so I just
would keep a quite a close communication
with Brandon and my dad and know a lot
about what's going on in the industry I
think one of the things that's really
fascinating to me is much like I was
very right about Burgundy's explosion a
decade ago I didn't let procedure that
were those yes and cold california cabs
shift yeah this is a change
I looked it for a few minutes but just
by logic you know once Parker became not
the only voice in line people started
saying things like okay I'm always
trying to set you up you know
what happened was as Parker became one
of the most important voices instead of
the only voice like he was for 15 years
along with Wine Spectator what happened
was people started deploying logic and
they said you know there's 20,000 cases
being made of Chateau La pre-owned or
Lafitte and there's 330 of this single
vineyard
you know burgundy and so just supply and
demand kicked in because so we got
Parker got kicked out of Burgundy there
was a lot of controversy there Carrie
cab and Roe and Rowan and you but but
you love Burgundy but no truth is I
won't speak to because I don't even
believe I never fully knew the story I
could recall it he had a controversy
with a couple producers he stopped were
really dirty that's why he brought on
Pierre Lonnie way back when when first
introduced another critic and so what
happened was burgundy just wasn't that
important to the high net-worth
individuals of America and then they
became it and then supply and demand
kicked in I believe the same thing will
happen to Barolo so my big prediction
here heritage Radio Network great nation
on the great nation we're bringing minds
of the people what bringing wine to the
people so the trend is the trend is if
you're a collector and you want to buy
some wine for your kids
weddings or like the guy who hosts shows
made some good money on flipping some
why you need some good bets
I would buy small tiny production highly
rated sought-after Barolo
Bruno jocose a red label stuff like
Quintero single vineyards you know
because I believe that Barolo will
become a dominant wine of choice of the
next generation because it fits in
between that Pinot Noir Cabernet cycle
if huh but the power let's just drop a
little knowledge God so the role is
Italian yes it's from the team onset
correct which is one of the great wines
it's made by Fabiola the greatest
Nebbiolo were people who know Tuscan
wines predominantly Sanja basic traits
and it's probably more burgundy in the
Bordeaux yes it's definitely we pour it
you can see your fingers through it but
it has a huge amount of power
more so than most peeing in the wars and
it definitely has an old-world style
less fruit and it's amazing with food
and it's very popular by the way if
you're anonymous this is a very big time
line if you're a hardcore wine person
listening you know this grape you know
this region nobis wine I just think
they're under priced in the same way
that I was going on yeah I mean symmetry
there's a ton of stuff at 50 60 70 and
when you go to like 90 and 120 I just
think those wines are going to be 500
and 800 in the next generation in their
category that's a really good way to put
it so that's exactly right and $18
Barolo to me is the equivalent quality
value of a $300 Bordeaux of a $300
burgundy of a $200 California tab so you
can really do some damage in the
quality/price ratio so take that to the
bank
because I agree with
I had up I think that could be gone
thank you but I have a question would
you save a role that implying that
costume line is the Super Tuscans and
all that has sort of been on the scene
on their course or barolo sort of I
think there's four passive I think it's
me a very similar thing to collectors
that that Omni haven't had to run that's
like that's right the Rick Rick who just
made his first big cheque at Goldman
Sachs at 28 he's going to buy at the
restaurant trying to press the girl that
he's trying to hook up with that night a
pig SS Akaya a
celaya he's not going to say hey baby
check out this you know aldo container
now you know and so to me that's where
the opportunity lies by the way Rick's
girlfriend in that scenario is Sally
all right so taking that trend let's
talk about trends social media Matt a
sec okay and I mean I said we'll get to
that as you were alluding to it because
I think burgundy which was not well
covered was now available on the
internet for town and all because you
know I wasn't it wasn't Alan Meadows her
account it wasn't Panzer it was it was
these a Robert Parker forums like it was
wine berserkers it was these nine wine
forums and auction prices that's right
that's right
but but but wait the high class Creek
the board the board room you know yeah
that's right that's right miss meetings
will come out his social why a lot a lot
so Nuria your you're strikingly handsome
son that's with us right now who's you
know waving to 2:00 in the morning
hooking up with chicks he and I know he
doesn't even starve it
he's been the star distress shouldn't
even started snaps Koran till 2:00 he
you know if he didn't know me and you he
exactly him how old are you now the 27
year old New Yorker make it a couple
bucks going out at night he's gonna
follow four or five sommelier
and actually produce his knowledge from
those people not from the Wine Spectator
and so that's how it's changed it right
he he's absolutely now being influenced
by Andre Mack or Lauren maniac or all
the thumbs that now post something and
so he's going to see a snap or an
Instagram review of a wine and he's
going to save it he's going to walk into
his local wine shop and be like do you
have this and so that's how so the base
of people who disseminate information
democratized they're reputable they're
retailer 100% people drink a lot of mind
I remember saying some things already a
community it is it's it's exact it's the
internet impact on society in every
category but most of all it's fun to
look back when I said in interviews
about Wine Library TV then I was the
preview not the anomaly as you know cuz
you follow the space I got a lot of
credit I was first I was first on
YouTube that was a good call I was first
I was the first person to carry a lot of
weight in the wine world that wasn't one
of the five or six wine magazines for
sure and so oh well that's right Wine
Library why my bikinis became this huge
thing I could sell a lot of wine or
killer wine people bought and drank wine
because of what I said and I was doing
it strictly through YouTube and what I
remember being right about was yeah I've
got some charisma and I've got my thing
and I'm going to be special but this is
going to happen for everybody anybody
good enough and what I also thought and
it played out was okay well I'm good on
video but as I remember thinking blogger
and WordPress because those are blogs
back that as you know I didn't really
know social nobody was I didn't know
social media was coming you know
and so obviously Instagram is we can all
who's listening understand one easy
platform for anybody to be a wine critic
take a picture a label write two
sentences
mazelTov
that's right for sure all right as a
matter of fact you should are you
creating conflict the wine that we're
about to taste and taste with other
guests we have Instagram right yeah I
guess snapchat okay we're on Twitter
don't worry I Celeste we've been known
Ben's ever had with me at vaynermedia
was hey I don't wanna be to pigeon-holed
as a snapchat guy I mean that's how
hardcore he is snapchatting never done
was that she's isalus let's shake let's
move away from why we have some good
insights on wine let's talk about you
know really where you establish your so
complain let's start with banner so you
guys build marketing machine which I
know this because I've been around you
from the beginning basically based on
your intuition you decided I'm going to
build this business here's what I'm
feeling this is what I'm going to tell
people is that an accurate portrayal of
what vaynermedia yeah I mean you know
bad I am building an agency full service
of everything so I can use it for myself
in my future business behaviors for my
whole life it's got to be so weird for
you because it was when we first started
meeting each other
pitching for the show you were down in
Tribeca the process space that's like
wait before there was we work and all
that that's why was it is really good
that's right honey and sunshine sweet
and you probably had 12 14 employees
that's what I tell people how big Jesus
is so back then we were that's probably
right 7 to 12 people doing you know 800
thousand a year and and now we're 725
735 people doing 100 million a year
we've done that in 7 years
so we globally run the whole thing it's
really cool you know it's a listen
I'm trying to say I know a lot of people
listening that don't know me so I'm
going to try to hedge on the ego here
I suck at a lot of stuff I'm a very good
businessman and if I decide to do
something I'm victory I have you here
yeah and you know I'll see you a lot
yeah and I can use this for the future
just tell me one thing is sucking Oh a
lot of things show you one they really
suck in science science okay everything
is not right what running fast I'm
fairly slow okay White Russian you know
but but to make any smoke um yeah talk
about it science and running all right
I'm so happy I mean I'd been around
advertising marketing a long time I
think the business has changed
incredible tell me your duration at
vaynermedia in general it changes yes
the differences I mean the first things
I walked into Campbell's perhaps see the
NHL they didn't even know what Twitter
was and not only like they hadn't
checked it out it was like hey guys you
should be on Twitter and Facebook and
they're like what's Twitter so part of
that answer is as social media was
coming into the advertising we were
there that was I was right that was URI
to hashanah bass that's an important
part of me it's the important part of
life right the time I married my wife
it's how I was built the wine business i
yes
JDate and the intuition of our first
date I was like this is my wife that was
a great decision
it's how I built Wine Library I was
right about the internet itself I was
right about Spanish Australian wines
when nobody wanted to hear it and then
wild duck mucks getting 100 points for
Parker I mean my mind narrative is
pretty basic like I I have a good nose
what I think I do really well is I bet
on it and so like for everybody
listening so this is less about me and
more about you like how about this next
year if you get anything out of the
great nation maybe this inspiring moment
how about for once in your life if
you've never
done it or for the people that have done
it a couple times but not in a long
while
how about just going all-in on something
you believe in like what are you waiting
for you say that all the time
I believe in it I know you that's why
you say and it's never too late for
anyone to go all-in
look at you would you be seriously I
love that about you
yeah no I mean don't go see humble now
you're stuck your character you know
what guys just so everybody knows he's
ready to beat he senses you're listening
for one of the great deeds of all time
and the way he takes compliments makes
me rap good news for if you haven't
picked up on it yet I'm great at taking
compliments I take them very easily and
to be very frank expect them but you
know yeah man look at you like you know
like you know there's all your yahoodi
5465 we're not you
oh you're 60 great whatever you put
there 64 yeah I tell you 61 you're 61 I
forgot
no you're not you're my mom's age that's
why I'm trying to do the math you're 61
and you feel like you're 16 to me ya
know and to me that's the blonde
that's a hard bounce around and by the
way I know 61 year old that our bed
because I come from a country where
people died at 16 so a lot of my moms
and dads contemporaries they think it's
55 you kind of shut it down I had lunch
day with Stephen lost my business
partner he owns the Miami Dolphins he's
one of the richest men in the world
right he's 76 the entire lunch was prior
yeah I was like listen if you keep
acting this way in modern medicine in 15
years you're gonna rolling this hard
he's like it was funny I was trying to
like kind of give him I was trying to
give him something he looked to me like
of course of course at 91 I'm gonna be
[ __ ] on fire Oh Jimmy shut up dick so
the nice thing about that to talk about
that's why you never business together
he can relate to you he's no one oh
forget about him for a second you think
I'm you sitting here yes it's you
weren't the same I mean you know like no
I you know it's not a number it's how
you roll it's what you do and by the way
let's try and tie this into the show can
you guys all please do me a favor if you
have not tried a style of wine ever
before go buy that wine tonight
if you never had a connect from your
glide if you've never had a birthday
hole from Spain if you've never had a
ban you'll which is late harvest panache
from the South of France
like stop any euros by the way
Beaujolais Nouveau is dead
it's lost all its momentum yeah kind of
a bunch of terrible joy that's real [ __ ]
so for me for me this works in the most
micro things like what you drink every
wine and it works with the most macro
levels of like your life it's that all
right so working at Vayner yes Nick
Boehner yes he came all over the country
yep world on global this past week I
think you Lisbon like that crazy let's
talk about we talked about wine social
media trend just kind of get me up to
date social media house partly happening
in a house party
what is house I know what it is hello um
well we tell our listeners I want to
hear you explain it well I'm not that
sure because I haven't embedded but I
got to the kid I think it's a video plan
yep multiple people get admitted to a
certain on what were six to get on
FaceTime and talk together and just you
know it's one of the six or eight hey
right it's a its upsells oh man this is
Ranger is a connection that's right so
it's a person thinks you know it's an a
person FaceTime if you want you love
this think about how many times you
wanted to watch that football game with
all three of your buddies but you're in
different places it's the closest thing
to replicating that that I've seen and
the onboarding is incredible like
warehouse parties running by the way
full disclosure this app used to be
called meerkat which I think some people
have heard of and I was invest for New
York a time before I get into like why I
believe in it but you should know that
but if you knew anything about me you
would know that I [ __ ] on my investments
as much as I hair hold them they've got
something right now so they're high like
I don't know it's very I wouldn't it's
early but it's got traction it's
happening Marco Polo
which is not an investment of mine but
another communication app video the
conversation like they've got some
traction so there's a little mergers
chant already sort of amateur they made
it they're gone public thing yes but
what's happening is instagrams future
copies have definitely slowed some of
snapchats growth and so it's been
fascinating cream reacted on 2% but but
how one reacts is the most important
thing no no no I know that they reacted
in a way that has been successful then
you are you have less news on your on
your snapchat over the last three months
and by the way from then how many do you
get once it rights or small numbers to
like you know tens of thousands pushing
100,000 we've all felt declines and and
so you know snapchats going to address
it on the flip side snapchat spectacles
and like there's just there's so many
things going on there's so much stuff
going down everybody talks about Twitter
and your smile yeah I don't know you
know to coffee because they're a public
company I hate to make predictions about
Twitter because the board may do
something another company that come in
into a hostile takeover by buying all
the stock like I don't know but I will
say this they didn't innovate enough
over a five year period and allows other
things to happen which allowed people to
you know chip away at their market share
they will never mainstream enough normal
people never fully understood it yeah
and I want to call in a pivot they
feature add think about snapchat they
ask shared every day it feels like
Instagram look at all these changes so
quick iteration matters in technology
companies and I don't think Twitter did
well in that way so the future not right
not bright but here's what I will say
that Twitter is needed we need a
water-cooler of society
so whether Twitter makes it or not I
don't know but much just as that is
everybody um I do think it can they need
to somebody again
what Facebook did to MySpace I think
somebody could do the Twitter looks a
lot like it some different
and you shall get inserted on the money
with my muse a hip idea was it their
inability to kinda carry it through it
was Jack's brilliance as an entrepreneur
and CEO to know to buy it it was very
hot uh yeah well they bought it and they
put into a big company and you're you've
been in corporate America you know how
that works
yeah what do you drink on Thanksgiving
we had Rolo oh [ __ ] which is great with
Turkey we had Shirley's infidel very
nice like a velvet hammer yep we we're
gonna penis with it when do we do one in
111 I created a character named Pino
Gina
it's your Twitter handle so that yeah
that is my drawing
fun fact Hannah 2003 hobbies yes
oh that's nice okay yes did you have
company the kids bring some fine yeah
all right so let's finish up because we
have a few of the juice to do let's talk
about being your RSD okay so you have an
opportunity to execute all your
experience and go out and invest in
companies and try to build companies a
tomorrow it's a little bit it's a fun
that I ran the last two three years all
the money is deployed in stable partners
we deployed 25 Steve Ross we deployed 12
yep we deployed 25 million dollars Matt
Higgins filter on toe carry Kellogg
sharing a bunch of people involved on
our side we made a big investment
snapchat good we made we made some big
invest
yep we just had a big Reggie could end
up being really good
we just had an exit beam Casey neistat's
company
nice that it's company I love saying to
CNN we've had some brave
cute I'm huge
brave which is sold to Turner we've had
a nice little run here we saw some great
companies pure well out there finger on
the pulse looking for the next thing yep
ready to him back yep put the money yep
Dora yes but I definitely never promised
that there's a couple of things you know
mcnac and investment we made I'm on the
board so I'm doing that but you know my
time is such an issue and so I never
wanted to [ __ ] anybody and say we're
going to overly mentor but I do and I
meet with my startups but I'm not to the
not to that level that may be a chapter
on my career in the future
but right now I'm just too busy
operating vaynermedia and then lastly
yes and it's sort of exciting because
what we like what we do being or sport
yes which is sort of do it
the newest manger thing yes wake up my
brother AJ left vaynermedia in March or
May
and we're now doing Vayner sports it's
Jerry Maguire we want to work for sports
that's right we'll do the marketing for
them as well help them get you know
sponsorship deals and we think we got
something we have analyzed the agency
world we think that a lot of sports
agents do not do enough by the
Challenger faces off I want to rip their
faces off that's exactly right thank you
for using one of my favorite terms are
there any parallels looking for the next
company for being RFC looking
purveyors for that's exactly right and
much like vaynermedia really disrupted
an established industry I want to do the
same in banner sports I want banner
sports to be a real player against CAA
and rock nation and things of that
nature and so I'm I'm excited about it
obviously about a year old
yes not even not even it's really not
even this is really our first class it
was what's called symmetry sports AJ and
I bought the majority stake we did Luke
Williams and Bryan and so they are
partners and they are the actual
registered NFL agents and so it's um
it's really exciting
yeah well thank you I mean how fun is it
when we eventually wrap a jet well just
full disclosure we were at the gym
tailgate in 20 years yeah he's with that
burning I'm a big college yeah we're
going to be nice on yeah he's in the CFL
great kid right your eyes on today's
daily me yeah yes I'm all right
yes that's the business part of it I do
a thing every week all the wine I don't
want to leave without it
okay so let's do it you can ask good one
spot it's still actually summer video
pretty good all right they're winery so
what why are you drinking now there's
something is Barolo the answer no this
is going to blow people's mind if they
follow my career I am drinking
California chardonnay will give you
something um what am i clinking a bunch
of olive they're Kistler cause I'm
drinking over there I've been drinking a
bunch of ol bear I've been drinking a
bunch of no yes I actually have been
drinking a little bit of em yeah these
are some expensive character sbrega
which make some that make some nice
single vineyards and it France here's
one that everybody can buy I see France
50th
Franciscan cuvee Sauvage so so cooks
family so for some reason a style of
wine I made fun of for a decade
in restaurants or pop and north and
thrilled and co-chair passing Hall and
thrilled if somebody makes fun of me
because I hug them in the face you know
so California chardonnay I'm proud of it
there's something that's hitting my
palate right now that works for me nice
unusual answers yep you be a favorite
wine and food pairing I would go with
late harvest Riesling from the all sauce
and Captain Crunch cereal okay sweet on
sweet Leone sweet eyes sweet squares
guarantee the listeners that that be
only time you'll ever hear yeah yeah I
favorite wine restaurant for wine bar
your place in the city that's and
rescuing your alibi I am um historically
it was crew and Veritas those were just
so fun for me that was the prime my
career and they were big wine
restaurants I love when terroir popped
up he crushed it he's the best trying to
think of those I feel like there was
actually something that kind of really
took me aback and I was in put up what
Yuma call it charlie bird has a fun list
yet he's but he's also beast and Robert
came from crew yeah uh yeah I mean I
would say I would say those standout all
right babe all hi my ideal answer good
good
so that's true I would tell you that
eighty-two salon champagne is moon and
I've said that in the past the fanciest
the fanciest wine I as like favorite
wine is forty seven shovel 47 shuttle
block but I was young I was young you'd
like to get there that I would I was
young and I feel like I forced it you
know how like ugly dudes get really hot
chicks when they're playing at explain
right so yeah so I feel like I feel like
I was built I was sold on the brand of
it
and so so eighty-two salon I think you
did a great job there I would say that
is way up there eighty-five Sassicaia
even though we're as
I read Tuscany a little bit earlier all
right so good answer okay reach back to
your retail experience okay in your car
now yes because my listeners focus best
wine under 15 bucks give me a red and a
white that's flying under the guy yeah I
got to go over to dinner with two
bottles cause some thirty and they drink
more expensive than they taste what's
the lines you should be carrying oh you
know what where's my phone actually Oh
then give me my phone actually I'm going
to answer so let me let me buy myself
some time because I'm actually going to
be a specific one for sure and you know
I have a waiver than this ten years
later Portuguese red wines are
incredible okay as any value and I think
those are incredible
so Tony ganache canal which is nerdy and
I apologize evidence so box globe
Chardonnay twelve bucks
available nationwide really good super
high on that and then pro meal Malbec PR
o-- e mio eleven dollars Malbec any now
that's a great great I know that been
you know live in Argentina or one of
those names you know so I'm a big fan of
that
eleven dollars thank you all right last
question for mock you know I'm an
investor and delectable but it seems
that Vivino has won that game seems like
everybody uses it I see it all the time
delectables around first I don't know to
be very honest for this I don't know and
then Bo came around
it's lovely now right yeah yeah the
people that hug of recession yes and the
binos always had a little bit of a
leader now it has a macro lead all right
so will you stay with us for our weekly
life
taste the delicious wine yeah let's do
it all right we're going to take a quick
break you're listening to the great
nation we've been talking to Gary
Vaynerchuk and we'll be right back
so Gary I've known for a while is
probably the most suit wine taster I
know he has an incredible nose of hell
so we're going to let Gary we're going
to take a snippy snip and we're going to
throw it over the tongue and let's talk
about what we're looking at and drinking
so this is such an iconic why first of
all thanks for sharing it um you know
the colors black dark unbelievably year
old wine which is incredible because
it's usually loses some of that
intensity on the nose it's got hardcore
black jam a little hint of really black
by the way like super juicy feels like
you're smelling red flute fruit
blueberries blackberries black fruit as
well for that reason a little hint of
tobacco on the nose on the tail end you
get a little smoke rabbi charcoal smoke
yep 100% whether it's a match or a
little bit tobacco it depends on your
nose that's what you'll get on the
palate so this is interesting right I
don't know for you rock you and then you
know depending on where your wine
palates are you can feel a little bit of
tannins on the back end but they're so
soft and usually it's better if you know
what how you use that puckery tough
flavor you taste when you taste red wine
the wrong this skins the see understand
yeah all the stuff that isn't the fruit
as you can imagine it by the way very
easy even if you're underage to learn
this go take a grape you'll eat the skin
versus eating the actual grape that
transcends into red wine it gets bitter
if you remember the old bitter beer face
commercials which I thought was really
funny by the way anyway nonetheless
what's great about this is this is what
aged wines all about this wine eight
nine ten years ago would have felt
hopped on the back end because the
alcohol and of course so this is an
elegant you know what this is
it's like a 42 year old distinguished
gentleman who's got a little gray coming
in right still hit likes was off it was
an absolute like boy band rocks are
handsome a nineteen heartthrob
Timberlake would be a great cop 42 year
old Justin Timberlake is what this wine
is and so I like that it's balanced long
finish I'm still tasting it and much
like 42 year old Justin Timberlake and
he's happily married so I don't want to
wish us on him but still has plenty of
game right this wine can probably last
another 15 years easily having the fruit
in the bottle I mean it's really good so
if we have a look at traditional reading
yes if I would do a Miami TV I'd
probably score this wine 96 plus points
which is high for you Larry you know 90
to 93 is a damn good one
this is a British drink his boss would
agree yeah why well yes I think even at
99 it was one of the most profound it
was great Avenue thanks for sharing
thank you for tasting with us
what would this pair with bloody red
needs Pittsburgh so piled black and blue
like huh all right all right if you have
a question a wine happening or an event
hit me up at sanma Creek Nation calm
that sama great nation follow us on
Twitter at benroubi and Instagram and
s10 relief oh thank you to our guest
Gary Vaynerchuk for taking time out of
his very busy schedule unless on the
great nation yep heritage radio network
is a member supporting nonprofit radio
station devoted to all things new and
why heritage needs your support during
the big end of your fundraiser a
contribution in any amount not only
supports atriums 34 weekly programs Oh
but also comes with exclusive member
benefits so if you like good food and
wine and you love good food and wine
radio drol will go our way yeah okay
well yeah you can go to Heritage Radio
Network org backslash donate
that's heritage radio network.org
backlash donate david my engineers show
me a t-shirt this is a t-shirt bottle
there are all kinds of couple things I
got to run cuz I'm missing a family out
school my daughter school function
alright that's how much I love you but
give two things one game is amazing - I
really wish you could recall my first
live radio read commercial which was an
utter disaster by the way I want to do
that you document it askgaryvee how do
you overcame so benroubi this wonderful
man that you listen to runs in that for
the first one I crush the creative but
then we get to the question has no you
know not actor nothing for vote nothing
I crushed the creative and it gets to
the commercial time I take the paper
this is something true I can't read
meaning like I'm not good at it so I
read this at it is literally the worst
execution of my career in public it was
like Bela beer is a beer it was it was
lowers it goes to commercial I'm like
I'm like holy crap that was the worst
thing I've ever done publicly he runs
into the booth he goes listen to me
Stern never read it neither he just did
stuff the next room you knew this look
at it right now make some note just do
do your thing the next time I came round
I don't know maybe all-time great rocks
are all tumbling rock I love him yet all
right Thank You Chuck you said some
champagne Ruby and you've been listening
to degrees great nation we'll see you
next time
you